YouTube Facebook happy Sunday morning
happy Father's Day to all the dads out
there Jordan right there good to see you
I just want to do a raw to the face
video on this Sunday morning we've been
doing a lot of keynotes a lot of daily
B's for YouTube and Facebook but I just
want to do a little rant from the kind
of the hip right from the dome just want
to thank you so much your comments are
my oxygen I say it over and over you'd
be blown away by how much I breathe with
feedback you know to me getting that
feedback from you guys is just amazing
and I'm just so grateful and thankful
and just wanted to make a raw kind of
quick video just thanking you so so so
much for all of that the community is
the game the process is the game and
I've hit that kind of quiet crescendo
moment where like it just I'm so in tune
with like putting out content putting it
out there letting you guys consume it
reading your feedback in this viral loop
and just feels like I'm in that zone and
every day I wish for you guys out there
in the world to find that same zone and
so look for that thing find that thing
and for me this community is that thing
and I want to thank you from the bottom
of my heart thank you so much have the
best best rest we can't have the best
summer flip start things produce content
but most of all listen you know the
audacity that everybody wants likes and
comments and subscribers but doesn't
want to then do for them what they want
to return the selfishness of like give
me vanity metrics and social and content
and digital yet the key is if you
listened and cared about those
individuals as much as what you wanted
from them and likes and subscribers
everything would be different
please do not take things for granted
and most of all do not take your
community for granted because it's the
foundation of your opportunity in this
digital world see ya